فيه ناس يسمّونهم (Stamp Collector) «جامع الطوابع»
هذول اللي يسافرون عشان بس يقول أنا سافرت عدد معين
يدخل بلد كم ساعة عشان يقول أنا سافرت الرقم الفلاني
بالنهاية طيب أنت أيش عرفت عن هذا البلد؟ ولا شيء
حتى أتذكر قابلت واحدة هنا جتّ السعودية أول ما فتحوا الفيزا
ما صدقت أن السعودية فتحت الفيزا، جوّ
والله ما جلست يوم في الرياض!
ونزلت في التواصل الاجتماعي أنها زارت السعودية
السعودية كاملة! تشوف الخريطة؟
تقول زرت السعودية وهي في الرياض ما جلست يوم حتى
يوسف السديس، مؤثر في مجال السفر والسياحة
وفي التواصل الاجتماعي صار لي تقريبًا أكثر من ثلاثة عشر سنة
لكن بالسفر زمان أكثر من عشرين سنة
ما أحب كلمة رحالة أبدًا
مشكلة رحالة أن الناس فهمتها بطريقة غلط
لأن الناس تعتقد دائمًا لما تقول رحالة
يجي ببالهم على طول واحد شنطته على ظهره ويتمشى ويركب مع ناس
وحياة مبهذلة خلينا نقول
سائح أو سوّاح
سوّاح أنا حاطها في «البايو» حقي
لأن برضه هذه نقطة ثانية لأني أبغى أوصل للناس ترى أنا سائح
لأنه في مجال السفر ما فيه شخص تقول هذا خبير
حتى لوأنه مثلًا صارت مشاكل أو أخطاء
أو أشياء ثانية
فأنا إنسان عادي
لست خبير وكل شيء أعرفه
في مجال السفر وفي كل مكان في العالم
صارت أشياء بسيطة، سافرت مع ناس قبل أصدقائي
علاقتنا مستمرة لكن السفرة خربت
الشخص اللي معاي بيروح ينام الحين
لازم نروح أو هذا الشخص يبغى مطعم معيّن
أو هذا الشخص اليوم ماله خلق يسوي كذا
صديقك اللي أنت تشوفه هنا تطلع معاه ساعتين أو ثلاث ساعات
قهوة وعشاء، وخلاص
لكن بالسفر معاك أربع وعشرين ساعة
بتمرون بكل المواقف
تعصبون على بعض وتتضاربون وتتفقون وتضحكون
عشان كذا أقولك فيه ناس اللي أحبهم أو قريبين
نقول لا ما نسافر مع بعض بتطلع مصائب
أنا ما أبغى أعرفها عنك وأنت ما تبغى تعرفها عني
فخلينا بعيدين
في بداية سفراتي كنت إنسان دقيق
وأخطط ولازم أعرف كل شيء عن المكان اللي أسافر له
هذا الكلام قبل أكثر من عشر سنين
بعدين وصلت إلى مرحلة أني ما أستمتع بالتخطيط
أو حتى بالسفرة إذا كانت مخططة
وقفت التخطيط من تقريبًا سبع أو ثمانية سنوات
أروح على عماها، المتعة أكبر وأكثر وأفضل
لكن عيبها طبعًا أنها بتكون مكلفة أكثر
بس أعرف أني بروح إلى هذه المنطقة
وإذا لقيت شيء بالطريق أوقف فيه
رحت هناك ما أعجبتني بكرة أغيِّر
صرت مرن جدًا في موضوع السفر
وهذا شيء خلّاني أستمتع بالسفر بشكل أكثر
أشوف أشياء جديدة وأجلس في المكان اللي فعلًا أعجبني
مو لأني رتبت لها
لأنه بالأخير سفراتي كسياحة ما أبغى أخليها كمهمة عمل
أتكلم عن سفراتي الآن
أنك تروح وعندك جدول يصير لازم تمشي على هذا الجدول
وتجلس ثلاث أو أربع أيام حتى لو البلد ما أعجبتك
هذه ما صارت سفرة
الحين تحتاج إجازة بعد الإجازة
يمكن، أنا قلت لك قبل شوي
كوبا هم يعيشون في حقبة زمنية من السبعينات
ما فيه إنترنت
حتى لو حصلت، مثل المودم حاطينه في حديقة معينة
بس هذه الحديقة اللي فيها الإنترنت
وعشان تشبك على الإنترنت هذا
تروح إلى المكتب وتقدِّم
تجيب جوازك وتعبي معلوماتك
وتدفع عشان بس تأخذ بطاقة إنترنت لمدة ساعة
وإنترنت سيئ جدًا لدرجة حتى محادثة واتساب ما تطلع
تخيل الموقف اللي كسر خاطري
ولد صغير عمره خمسة عشر أو سبعة عشر
يجي يقول لي أنا سمعت
طبعًا كان يتكلم إنقليزي، مبسوط
سمعت أنه أنتم معاك جوالك وفيه إنترنت طوال الوقت
سمع
قلت له طيب أنت الآن بتخرج مع أصدقائك في هذا الوقت، كيف؟
قال لي أن عندهم بطاقات الإنترنت اللي أقولك عنها ولكن
بعدد بيانات معين
يخليها على أطول مدة وأيش يسوي؟
يروح إلى المكان حق الإنترنت ويدخل يروح على الإيميل
و يرسل إيميل لصاحبه، شوفوا التعقيد
في الوقت والمكان المعين
والشخص الآخر وقت فتحه للرسالة، يمكن يفتحها قبل أو بعد. ما تدري
أغلب الشعب طبعًا ما عنده جوال
يروحون إلى كبينة التلفون أو حتى سوبرماركت أو البقالة الصغيرة
يعطيه فلوس ويستخدم تليفونه
والناس كلها تلقاهم مثلًا عند بيوتهم يخرجون إلى عتبة الباب
يسولفون الجيران مع بعض
هذه الأشياء ما تشوفها الحين في أي بلد
أعتقد زيلامسي في النمسا
لأنه ما فيها شيء مختلف
عن باقي البحيرات في سويسرا والنمسا
طبيعة سويسرا والنمسا معروفة
من أجمل الأماكن الطبيعية في العالم
فما كان فيها أي إضافة أو شيء مختلف عن باقي البحيرات
بالإضافة إلى أنها كانت زحمة
تكون الأسعار فيها مرتفعة وما تلقى مكان سكن
وتحس البلد صارت فوضى مع الزحمة
لأنها صغيرة جدًا
بالنهاية ما في أي شيء مختلف
تطلع أي بحيرة ثانية جنبها نفس الشيء
أنت بالنمسا، وين ما تروح المكان جميل
الطبيعة يعني
ترى هذا برضه نقطة مهمة جدًا
عامل الإنبهار مع كثرة السفر يصير نادر جدًا أنه يصير لك
من فترة إلى فترة بس
وتقول أنا أنبهرت من هذا المكان
ولما تنبهر تقول تمام، حصل شيء جديد مختلف
قبل ما أروح وأنا في الرياض كلمتني شركة جوالات
قالوا بنعطيك جوال، إعلان وتصور فيه. قلت تمام
تدرون كيف؟ أنا عندي رحلة الأسبوع الجاي
خلوني أخذ الجوال الجديد معاي عشان أصور فيه وأنا مسافر
بالعكس بيكون فيه تأثير أكبر
معاي جوالي العادي والجديد، الآن معاي جوالين
وأنا في الطيارة
قلت الحين خليني أجرب الجوال
تعرف جوال جديد ما أعرف استخدمه
لأنه من شركة ثانية غير عن جوالي
فتحته بالطيارة وخرجته من الكرتون
ما فيه بطارية، قلت تمام خليني أشحنه
في الطيارة، فتحت مكان الشحن وحطيته في الشاحن
ونمت إلى أن وصلت
لما وصلت، هي رحلة «ترانزيت»
كانت المدة قليلة، وإحنا وصلنا متأخرين
لازم بسرعة عشان نلحق على الطيارة الثانية
على طول أخذت أغراضي وركبت الطيارة الثانية
ولما وصلت فتحت شنطتي
أشوف الكرتون، كرتون الجوال حطيته في الشنطة
لكن الجوال نفسه يشحن
يا ساتر! نسيته في الطيارة
عمومًا، أول يوم طلعنا ومعاي جوالي العادي
أول يوم طلعنا ورحنا إلى مكان سياحي
يطيح الجوال وينفتح إلى نصفين
أول مرة بحياتي جوالي ينكسر إلى هذه الدرجة
مو شيء يتصلح، انكسر تمامًا
نمت وصحيت اليوم الثاني وما أعرف الساعة كم
ما كان معاي ساعة، وما عندي جوال
وغرفة الفندق ما فيها ساعة
تخيّل، أتصلت على الاستقبال: مرحبًا، الساعة كم؟
حسيت يقول سكران. يستهبل كيف الساعة كم؟
أعتقد في الصين وفي كوبا
شوف تركيا
أنا ما عندي مشكلة أني أروح لها لكن ما أشوفها تختلف
لأنها جنب اليونان
وحتى أنا كنت في اليونان في جزيرة كوس
عن بودروم أقل من نصف ساعة
فهي نفس الطبيعة ونفس الشيء
أكل لذيذ وطبيعة والجو وكل شيء
لكن بالنهاية لو أنت في أجمل مكان في الدنيا
وشخص يعاملك معاملة سيئة
ما بيهمك جمال المكان وبتكرهه وتمشي
أنا دائمًا أقول
الشعب هم سبب تخلي الناس تحب البلد أو لا
مو موضوع طبيعة أو جو أو أكل
طبعًا هذه كلها عناصر تضيف
أشوف الشعب رقم واحد
في بالي في إندونيسيا
اللي هو عندهم يوم الصمت
اعتقاد أن الأرواح الشريرة تجي على كل البلد
أي أحد طالع
يمشي في الشارع أو يفتح النور
أو يتكلم صوت عالي
أو يمارس أي نشاط طبيعي يومي
بتتلبّسه هذه الأرواح
في يوم الصمت عندهم يقفلون كل شيء
كل المطاعم
المطار يقفل
المطاعم والأنشطة و كل شيء
كأنها تصير مدينة أشباح فعلًا
تطلع في الشارع ما فيه أحد
ولا تقدر تطلع إلى الشارع، ممنوع
حتى لو أنت سائح وجالس في الفندق ما تطلع من غرفتك
لو تبغى تطلب أكل
تطلب قبل وتخليه عندك لأن أصلًا ما فيه أحد يشتغل
الموظفين كلهم يروحون
ما تقدر تشغل نور أو نار حتى على الشاطئ أو في أي مكان
عشان كذا يسمّونه يوم الصمت
ما تتكلم ولا أحد يتكلم
اليوم اللي بعده يكون احتفال كبير
احتفال أن الأرواح الشريرة راحت عن بلدنا
الحين ما فيه أرواح شريرة لأننا ألتزمنا بالصمت والهدوء
كان شيء غريب أو اعتقاد غريب
رحت إلى زنجبار في تنزانيا
وصلت وكان واحد ينتظرني من الفندق
واسمي مكتوب في اللوحة
قلت تمام أنا معاه
رحت ركبت لحالي طبعًا، الساعة إثنين في الليل
وفعليًا أول مرة أزور تنزايا وزنجبار وهذا أوّل شخص أشوفه
نمشي وهدوء وظلام
رايحين، وفي وسط الطريق هوودّه يتأكد
بعد ما طلعنا من المطار
أن الشخص اللي معاه هو نفس الشخص، بس بيتأكد
فيقول لي وهو يسوق يقرأ: السيد يوسف السديس
قلت إيه، صار يطالع فيني
يقول السديس؟ قلت نعم
السديس؟ نعم!
ويوقف في وسط الشارع
طبعًاً أنا خفت، أيش السالفة؟
في وسط الشارع، والله ما وقف على اليمين
الحمد لله أنها كانت الساعة إثنين بالليل وفاضية الشوارع
في وسط الشارع يوقف
ويلتفت علي، السديس؟
قلت الله يستر، فيه أحد من قبل نفس الاسم مسوٍّي له مشكلة
نزل من مقعد السائق وجاء إلى عندي ويفتح الباب
أنا كنت مستعد أضرب على طول، قلت الموضوع اختطاف
وجلس يتبرك فيني
و ما فيه آية يعرفها أو دعاء إلّا يقوله ويتبرك فيني
ما كنت أتوقع هذا الشيء يصير
أبدًا، آخر شيء كنت أتوقعه
فهو باعتقاده لأنه مسلم
السديس مرتبط عنده في مكة
وعلى أساس أنا جاي من مكة
وهو حلم حياته أنه يروح إلى مكة
قلت له أنا السديس لكن مو من مكة
تمام أنا من السعودية، بس من الرياض
الله يعطيك العافية، شرفتنا
الله يعافيك
وشكرًا لكم يعطيكم العافية، ما قصرتوا
ومعليش إذا تكلمت كثير وطوّلنا
صفقة كذا بس؟
تسلم، ما قصرت